if God is
unchanging why does he appear to change
his mind or actions such as Genesis 67
that's
easy2 all right you already know what
he's asking okay well know he's asking
yeah brother you you have a wrong view
of
unchanging okay so I'm gonna Define I
just did a session on this entirely hold
on one second let me go off camera I
need to sit down I'm not as young as you
if i s on my chair I can't do it okay
good question I just did a session on
this not too long ago
by unchanging the Bible
defines unchanging the mean God is
always consistent with his nature
consistent with himself and will not
deny himself and go against his
character so now let me shock you on
this believe it or not the fact that God
quote unquote changes his mind quote
unquote changes his mind is proof that
he's unchangeable I know that sounds
paradoxical what do I mean I need you to
listen because the passages you're
citing is God threatening to punish and
Destroy Sinners but then changes his
mind by then relenting from destroying
them and let's see why so open up for us
Jeremiah 18 brother we're going to read
the first 12 verses all day huh yeah D
we got about half an hour hour we're
gonna go out so go do eat something and
my my oldest my my beautiful firstborn
is here with me and my baby's in the
other room all right all right so first
four uh first 12 chapters 18 but you're
going to have to share the
screen okay now read for a SL now guys
this actually proves God is unchanging
if you define what unchanging means what
unchanging means okay let's see what it
means read for me from verses one down
the word came to Jeremiah from the Lord
arise and go down to The Potter's House
and there I will let you hear my words
so I went down to the 's house and there
he was working at his wheel and the
vessel he was making of clay was spoiled
in The Potter's hand and he reworked it
into another vessel as it seemed good to
the Potter to now let me break that down
a Potter takes clay to design something
good beautiful from it but sometimes the
clay spoils in his hand now was it the
intention of the Potter to spoil the
clay Avery no so what God is saying is
you are clay in my hand and I am now
fashioning you for a greater good
because God's desire is not to harm or
hurt or punish but to bless and prosper
you but if you end up spoiling yourself
in his hands because of your sin God is
still able to take you spoiled it all
and refashion you into something good
this is the
analogy what happened now that's Bible
that's Bible Sam did y'all catch that
that's that's Bible right there you got
a that's a word if that in the sermon I
don't know hey Seeker that's a word
ain't it Seeker
that's all right keep keep going that
was good okay so now God is gonna say
you see that example that's me you're
clay you spoiled yourselves but I can
still refashion you for good now read
five to
12 all right 5
to2 then the word of the Lord came to me
oh House of Israel can I not do with you
as this Potter has done declares the
Lord behold like the clay in The
Potter's hand so are you in my hand oh
House of Israel if at any time I declare
concerning a nation or a kingdom that I
will pluck up and break down and destroy
it and if that Nation concerning which I
have spoken turns from its evil I will
relent of the disaster that I intended
to do to now I'm gonna engage you guys
pay
attention God being unchangeable means
he is faithful to his nature he's
consistent with his nature cannot go
against his nature so if God says to a
nation I'm going to bless you that
Nation now turns and becomes wicked and
evil and now blast Blasphemous if God
were to continue to bless that nation in
spite of its wickedness would he remain
faithful to his
nature yep he remain faithful to his
nature think about it again you didn't
hear the question because I know you in
love bro she ready to get married if God
promises to bless a nation but the
nation turns and becomes wicked and evil
and blasphemous and he goes ahead and
blesses it anyway oh would he be
faithful to his nature no he wouldn't no
that's why he says I can't continue to
bless you so ironically in saying I'm
going to bless this nation but then
turning back to punish it he's actually
proving he's unchangeable because he's
faithful to his nature because if he
were to continue to bless that means he
is going against his nature and now he's
actually changing yeah that's good you
got it there yep now the other part the
other
part keep reading okay uh where was I at
okay so verse nine and if at any time I
declare concerning a nation or a kingdom
that I will build it and plant it and it
does evil in my sight not listening to
my voice then I will relent of the good
that I had intended to do to it okay now
understand the opposite first he says if
a nation is evil and
wicked but then turns from its
wickedness I will then relent from
destroying it but if a nation is good
and righteous but it turns from its
righteousness I will relent from
blessing it if God were to punish a
nation that turns from Evil and
repents would God be then faithful to
his character to himself when he says he
desires none to perish but they repent
and live so if you're a wicked Nation
God says I want to punish you but then
you turn and he goes and punishes anyway
would he be faithful to himself
no and if he were to continue bless the
nation that turns from righteousness
would he be faithful to himself no so do
you see in this ironic Paradox by God
not remaining the same in his approach
to people depending on how they respond
he's proving he is
unchangeable that's good that's good
that's irony of it that's good so you
see the irony of it yeah get back on
camera man I need to see your face when
you breaking this down man okay okay I'm
say because yeah I wanted to walk around
I want to see my daughter any the the
irony is if God says I'm going to bless
this nation because it's prosperous and
doing righteous all of a sudden becomes
Wicked and if God were to continue to
bless it that means now he is changing
because he's now rewarding Injustice and
evil that means he's now becoming unjust
and his nature is
changing yeah so then he's got to stop
blessing and now
bring justice but the opposite if a
nation's Wicked he says I'm going to
destroy that Nation but it cries out to
God like Nevan Jonah that's what he's
referring to and they cry out to God and
God says well the hell with you I'm G to
punish you anyway that means god went
against his nature when he says I
Delight that the wicked repent and live
because I don't take pleasure in
destroying them that means now he went
against his nature y so ironically
because God is not a static immobile
being
but he's the Living God and he truly
interacts with his creatures and he gets
personally involved with his creatures
he has no choice but to act in a way
that is faithful to his nature in
response to what you
do you see it that's excellent now I'm G
finish it all the way to 12 because I'm
going to show you Exodus 32 proves this
point
okay all right
now therefore say to the men of Judah
and the inhabitants of Jerusalem thus
says the Lord behold I am shaping
disaster against the clay right he's
forming disaster clay okay I am shaping
disaster against you and devising a plan
against you return everyone from his
evil
way and amend your ways and your Deeds
so what is God saying here turn though I
am planning to destroy you for your sin
I don't want that yeah I want you to
turn and now I will refashion your
destiny one from destruction to blessing
but then God knows their response
because notice in verse 12 what he says
they're going to say but they
say that is in vain we will follow our
own and will everyone act according to
the stubbornness of his evil heart so
now is God being more than fair and
telling them I don't want to do this
turn and I'll refashion your destiny but
he goes but look they don't want to turn
because they love their sin leaving no
choice but to them bring destruction so
is God being just and fair he's being
just and fair and unchanging Sam now the
other example final one we'll finish the
point Exodus 32 because now watch what
people miss this is one you see God
changes Well yeah if you want to say
change part of God's unchanging nature
let me put it this way I'm going to go
off camera just one second part of God's
unchanging nature I want you to listen
the guy who asked the question is that
he must act Faithfully in accord with
his nature in response to your
choices so if you are going to become
Wicked and turn from God he cannot
continue to bless you because that means
he's rewarding Injustice and God is
being unjust yeah but if you turn and
fear God and he goes and destroy you
that means he's no longer being faithful
and being merciful and compassionate not
wanting any to perish now when you go
read seven Exodus 32 largest screen I
don't know if it's large enough I can't
see it but if you can see it read from
Seven all the way to 14 and the Lord
said to Moses go down for your people
whom you brought up out of the land of
Egypt have corrupted themselves they
have turned aside quickly out of the way
that I commanded them they have made for
themselves a golden calf and have
worshiped it and sacrificed it to uh sa
sacrificed to it and said these are our
Gods oh Israel who brought you up out of
the land of Egypt what a spit in God's
face and the Lord said to
Moses I have seen this people and behold
it is a stiff necked people now
therefore let me alone that my wrath may
burn hot against them and I may consume
them in order that I may make a great
nation of
you but Moses implored the Lord his God
and said oh Lord why does your wrath
burn hot against your people whom you
have brought out of the land of Egypt
with great power and with a mighty hand
why should the Egyptians say with evil
intent did he bring them out to kill
them in the mountains and consume them
from the face of the Earth turn from
your burning anger and relent from This
Disaster against your people it is
remember Abraham Isaac and Israel your
servants to whom you swore by your own
self you swore by your own self and said
to them I will multiply your Offspring
as the stars of heaven and Al and all
this land that I have promised I will
give to your Offspring and they shall
inherit it forever and the Lord relented
from the disaster that he had spoken of
bringing on his people he changed his
mind no okay guys let me show you what
people Miss read verse 10 Again read
verse 10 watch your watch it now
therefore let me alone that my wrath may
burn hot against them and I may consume
them in
order in order to make a great God just
gave a condition guys this why we got to
read the Bible more deeply he said leave
me alone so my wrath will burn against
them in other words if you don't leave
me alone my wrath will be
appeased the condition is Moses leave me
alone to destroy them and I'll make you
a great nation so this teaches two
things number one it teaches that God
will even act in accord with those whom
he loves and are highly exalted and are
close to his heart showing you the power
of
intercession right there Moses leave me
alone and I'll destroy them make you a
great nation in other words if Moses
does not leave God alone but beseeches
God then God won't carry out his wrath
so it's not only God saying it's not
unconditional it's not I'm G to wipe
them out I'll wipe them out if you leave
me alone and let me pour up my wrath in
other words it's an invitation to
Moses yeah if Moses is that selfish
self-centered where he only cares about
himself and says go ahead God then all
the descendants of Abraham would come
through Moses and Moses alone so here
was an opportunity to expose Moses's
heart is Moses self-centered and has
Moses care for himself to the point that
he doesn't care about the well-being of
others if so he doesn't have the heart
of Christ but in engaging God he shows
that he is a man after God's heart no
God it's not about me it's about your
reputation and your glory and your love
to the Patriarchs you swore you bring
their descendants therefore do as you
say let the Egyptians say you are
powerless to save the seed of Abra he
showed his heart yeah awesome so it's
conditional leave me alone Moses didn't
and then because he didn't leave him
alone God didn't pour out his wrath so
this was an opportunity of God to show
look at why
Moses is the most humble man on Earth
numbers 12:3 why I speak to him face to
face why he's greatly honored my sight
because he is not curved inwardly it's
not about him and about his greatness
it's about the love of the people
reflecting my heart the heart I have for
the Seed of
Abraham
amen so there that's also